what a cool project to be a part of like
if you when you talk about like dream
sort of
voices to be able to do something in the
monsters universe has got to be up there
when they said
hey uh you guys want to be part of this
i'm assuming it was like an immediate
yes yeah i mean i it certainly it was a
no-brainer for me
and and and it continues to be i think
the most impressive thing to any of my
friends or
family uh that i've done to date and it
hasn't even come out yet so
yeah and i i share in that enthusiasm
yeah the anticipation is
huge in my household you know
i think that's when my kids were like
three and four
we were introducing them to the monsters
movies
and how much of a sensation it was in my
house
i'm imagining that your kids are going
to be watching this too and when they do
are you going to be like
uh that that one's mommy that's that's
me or you're just going to let let it
slide and let them kind of figure things
out mindy you know i have a
three-year-old
and uh she is i think a little on the
little
because like i i agree nothing would
make me happier than showing it to her
and having like uh that's mom and
happened to be so impressed i think
she's going to have to be older until
she thinks it's cool because i honestly
right now she loves
monsters inc the movie so much that
she's just going to be about
mike and sully she'd be like why would
you ruin it with these new people
but i think the characters this show has
really jumped the ship
the shark yeah but um i think uh
i think she'll i mean i know she's gonna
love the show
my my kids my kids i've shown them
trailers and
my son the older one who's also three uh
he
he's not he's so unimpressed that when i
say that that's me that he's just kind
of
just like yeah i know and then that's
sort of it and then he'll walk away
my younger one just points at me and
goes purple
can you talk to us about who your your
characters are because mike and sully
everybody knows them right like they're
so they're ubiquitous but
when it comes to your new characters can
you tell us a little bit about who they
are mindy maybe starting with you
yeah i play val little who is a
works in mift and mifft is the kind of
subterranean
not very prestigious like physical
operations part of monsters
so even among monsters it's considered
like eh
not the best place to work and she
what's really funny about her
is that she doesn't care she thinks it's
the best place in the world she's so
earnest and positive and um she really
is one of those people that thinks of
work as her like you know as her family
yeah and and my character uh tyler
tuskman uh
didn't want to be certainly doesn't want
to be a part of mifft
monsters inc facilities team uh he is
there because
he he spent his whole life uh getting
ready and preparing to be a scarer
and then his first day of work uh they
they change over to laugh
laugh energy and laugh power and so he's
just laser focused on figuring out how
to be funny and how to get in
to the laugh floor and and to be one of
the jokesters
i know you guys didn't really get a
chance to record this together
but how much of a pinch me is it still
that you know that you are doing this
with billy crystal
and john goodman i have so many
screenshots from a minute ago when we
were on
with both of them and i will be sending
them out to everybody i know so
uh i'm i'm geeking out i consider them
dear friends i don't
you know i don't put them on the same
pedestal that ben does
they're doing their zoom from another
room in in the house that you're in
right now right you guys live together
no i mean it's incredible it's like and
include
henry in this too where it's like
between
the the movies that they've done and
obviously when harry
metally is like iconic to me and um the
big lebowski and
barry you know it's like they've done so
much incredible stuff and what's amazing
about those three actors in particular
is that um you know ben and i come well
ben does drama
ben has done both but i think if you
could do both drama and comedy i'm like
just blown away by you
so you know all the actors i get to work
with on this
can do both so that's really cool yeah
it's really it's it's a
i mean treat is putting it lightly um
now before we go finally mindy
your um your team and never have i ever
put together
the live table read in support of give
india i just want to ask you about how
proud you are
uh of that and give you an opportunity
to speak on that a little bit
yeah absolutely i felt
i was blown away by people's generosity
um you know people watching the table
read and netflix but i have to say the
thing that really touched me was that it
came
from the cast it came from my tree
feeling helpless and wanting to do
something
and we threw it together really quickly
um i was actually worried like how many
people would even
know to show up and we made i think
about a hundred thousand dollars
to send for for coveted in india so i
was
i was so pleased we could do it it's
amazing amazing well congratulations on
that and congratulations on the show
uh i'm so excited to kind of like
reintroduce my kids to the monsters
world through this so it's going to be a
good time thanks a lot you guys thank
you
thank you carlos cheers
you